c'est une vaste offensive que s'apprête
à lancer gérald darmanin des mosquées
vont être la cible d'une action massive
et inédite
le ministre de l'intérieur l'a annoncé
en ces termes ce mercredi conformément à
mes instructions
les services de l'état vont lancer une
action massive et inédite contre le
séparatisme 76 mosquée soupçonné de
séparatisme vont être contrôlés dans les
prochains jours et celles qui devront
être fermés le seront dans son tweet
gérald darmanin renvoie à un article du
figaro le texte dévoile une note envoyée
aux préfets un document dans lequel le
ministre de l'intérieur donne plus de
détails sur les mosquées se trouvant
dans sa ligne de mire
seize sont situés en région parisienne
les 60 autres dans le reste du pays
parmi ces mosquées 18 sont décrites
comme des cibles prioritaires
certaines qui ont ignoré une première
décision de fermeture se trouve en seine
saint denis
la majorité de ces mosquées dites cibles
prioritaires sont localisés dans le
reste du pays notamment dans l'hérault
le nord et le bas rhin
elles vont être l'objet d'une action
immédiate qui peut aller jusqu'à la
fermeture du lieu de culte
une annonce qui arrive à une semaine du
prochain conseil des ministres
il doit examiner le projet de loi
comportant les principes républicains
qui vise à lutter contre l'islam radical
et les séparatismes un texte qui sera
présenté par gérald darmanin et sa
ministre délégué à la citoyenneté
marlène schiappa
[Musique]